[Music]
hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga red this week we're once again
turning our attention to the Middle East
conflict that in recent days exploded
into the deadliest violence in the
region in five years and where tensions
have again flared between Washington and
Tehran over Iran's threatened partial
withdrawal from the 2015 nuclear deal in
Israel even the singers and musicians
taking part in next week's Eurovision
Song Contest carried out rehearsals
against a backdrop of sirens and
detonations the radical Islamist Hamas
group fired hundreds of rockets into
Israel which responded with airstrikes
on 350 militant targets inside Gaza the
results more dead and wounded on both
sides so what has triggered the latest
violence and will it shortly be resumed
so our question on quadriga this week is
Middle East conflict no song of peace
and to discuss that question I'm joined
here in the studio by Hassan Kadare an
independent writer who commutes between
Ramallah and Berlin and says the
two-state solution is the only possible
and realistic option in town also with
us is Alan Posner regular commentator
for the Berlin based daily de Velde who
says there will be no peace for the
Jewish state as long as Iranian backed
terrorists rule the Gaza Strip and a
warm welcome to to Deutsche Welle zone
Charlie Rose honest who's a producer and
commentator with DW now Shaunie argues
that for peace to come leadership on
both sides needs to take bold steps
thank you all three once again for being
here today and I'd like to begin with
you has incurred air and ask you to tell
us what people in the Palestinian
territories particularly in Gaza are
saying about the latest violence and
about the latest ructions between Iran
and the u.s. Iran and much of the rest
of the world when he would say well I
can say that people in Gaza are really
helpless and they find themselves in
vicious circle and they don't know how
to get out of it we are not happy with
the rule of
for sure and if we will have elections
tomorrow I'm not sure that Hamas will
win this is one thing but you're not
sure the Hamas would win but you said
that everybody's against Hamas yeah it's
just putting it in a mild way Hamas will
lose for sure yes in Gaza
so this is one point the second people
in Gaza they find himself between mr.
Netanyahu right-wing government and
Hamas rule in in Gaza and both of them
in fact are depending on each other and
mr. Netanyahu is authorizing and
permitting cash money transfer from
Israel to Hamas in order to pay salaries
of their people so when you ask about
with people in gollum so this is what
some people call the symbiosis between
Hamas and Prime Minister Netanyahu
perhaps we are I mean this is what David
Miller are on David Miller said or wrote
few weeks ago in the Foreign Affairs
explain who David Miller is front view
it was a high official in the Obama
administration and an intellectual I
mean in American Jewish community and a
contributor to the Foreign Affairs and
he wrote that there are two enemies who
claim that they want to destroy each
other but in fact they are depending on
each other and this is the virtuous
circle so when you ask about people in
Gaza they are helpless but nevertheless
Shani Prime Minister Netanyahu says the
campaign is not over and he adds the
situation requires patience and judgment
what do you expect next from mr.
Netanyahu well it's hard to tell I think
he would first like to get his his ducks
in a row get the government building
mission done have his own coalition and
then move forward especially considering
the fact next week we see the Eurovision
Song Contest today Thursday this week we
have the independence a is for Israel
this week for Israel is a very special
week in the national you know ëthis
everybody coming together he wouldn't
want any controversy any talks about war
two or bombs nonetheless you know like
we've had last week
in the south to be to be casting a
shadow over that particular time I think
Netanyahu is he keeps he keeps all
option on a table because this ambiguity
is is the only card he's been playing
for a long time even the ceasefire
brokered with Hamas is never officially
acknowledged never officially announced
by Israeli side it's always going
through third third side mediation and
third side announcements of what's
happening I won't be surprised if we
will see escalation coming around let's
say late June early July what do you
think and we just have this the list
from Sean either the killings on both
sides Memorial Day Independence Day
Eurovision Song Contest the ructions
between Iran and the US and others it's
a potent cocktail or what do you make of
it
well first I take umbrage at this what
you said what you said about killings on
both sides let's be clear about this
there was an attack from the Gaza Strip
on Israel unprovoked premeditated terror
which killed innocent civilians and by
the way also killed civilians in Gaza
because one rocket which wouldn't reach
Israel landed on a house killed a mother
and her child which was blamed on Israel
repeated by the Western media for hours
and hours and hours after Israel denied
this this is the reality in in in Israel
we saw it in the in in the opening clip
Israel has been subject to a terrorist
attack which no other nation would have
responded things there were killings on
both sides well obviously if you respond
is like saying there were killings on
both sides after 9/11 America was
attacked America and the world struck
back that's what Israel does that's what
the terrorists who rule the Gaza Strip
let's be quite clear Hamas is a
designated terrorist organization which
rules as dictators over Gaza and after
we've heard a couple of weeks ago there
were protests in Gaza food protests and
so on they attack Israel because that's
always a good idea isn't it let's attack
the Jews always what ladies listen to
what girls are born Hassan has to say
about well
think I can't go to our it's what you
said is completely wrong who started and
it's it's something like which is first
the egg or the hand no I mean in Haaretz
if you read her or it's carefully in the
last few days and then you will get a
different impression and that the
provocation was coming from the Israeli
side but this is not the point who is
provoking I mean the other this is not a
good point at all the point is the
virtuous circle and the point is why
there is no possibility of breaking this
virtuous circle and getting out of it in
order to save lives both in Gaza and in
Gaza and in solving Israel yes at the
point but who started and will show no
this is okay Shani first of all I want
to commend Allen for the heat you know
and the passion in in this discussion
because it seems like people from the
outside maybe are far more passionate
about it almost then people from the
region that are just somewhat fed up we
know this circle we know this routine of
attacks counter-attacks and you know
ceasefire money transfer and and it
seems like and that's I think somewhat
of what my distinguished colleague he
was saying we need to break that pattern
somebody needs to break that pattern
nobody is surprised nobody I think in
the region even deals anymore with who
started one way to break the pattern
would be I have a quote from an Israeli
man from Ashdod where one man was killed
in a rocket attack in recent days point
made this Israeli gentleman said when we
have the upper hand we need to once and
for all finish the terror because it
will repeat itself and it will not stop
do you agree with that sentiment Allen
we need to finish the terror wipe out no
there's no no no about terror let's say
wipe out Gaza that what it means what is
it wiping out terror how do you know
that otherwise no III understand there I
understand so you're saying people here
are action recetas as I am Peter's just
told us that actually people who are
exposed to the attacks
respond even harder with the more
emotion and I do and I would if I lived
in Ashkelon Ashdod and we've all been
there we know what it's like to be
little that I okay so in the South are
suffering people in Gaza are suffering
people in the West Bank are suffering
there's no doubt there's real human
suffering okay so what if we've
established that then the question is
you can't wipe out terror george w bush
tried it with the war on terror
we've been fighting this war on terror
germany as part of the of the of the
fight from from afghanistan to Mali and
that's not you know it's a long war
right but part of this war is not to
attack the periphery which Gaza is but
to attack the center and that terror on
Tehran which is now walking away from
the from the atomic guru
behind all the conflicts if you see in
this region you have Tehran they are the
people who encouraged the Syrian
dictator Bashar to Massacre his people
they are the people who behind his Bala
they are the people who were behind
Hamas they are the people who were
behind the civil war in Yemen it's all
down to the theocracy
to say well this is what in the Camp
David negotiations when bigan was
negotiating with Sadat
he was always telling him that let us
agree on this agreement so now let us
agree with this agreement I don't agree
with you it's the Palestinian problem
question whatever you call it it started
started decades before Tehran and it's
different if you are talking about
support I think the main support Hamas
in Gaza is getting a support from the
Qatar and this is an ally of the United
State and they have very good relations
with mr. Netanyahu government so I mean
don't look for or don't connect
everything together in order to make
such an argument that it's a war on
terror and it on and this is the center
this is not the point what I'm saying is
a Jew Inspira see the
palestinian-israeli conflict started
many many decades before and
unfortunately before Iran I mean
unfortunately it will or it may still be
many decades after Tehran and this is
the problem assuming we buy Alan's
theory it's all about Iran and it might
just be but even those where the
government is not speaking Yunus I'm
even Ateneo himself who is he was the
master of depicting Iran as they you
know they had the head of the snake and
so on
he's very much matéo complying with
Qatari intervention into Gaza with money
transfers we're talking millions and
millions every month and Qatar and Iran
our allies are talking you know for
talking in the axis we're talking Qatar
Iran against Saudi Arabia and American
forces where Israel should be aligned
with so Netanyahu himself is letting
irani irani allies into the backyard of
of his own I love this argument everyone
says you know gaza is the biggest
concentration camp in the world nothing
gets in there the poor people of gaza
and then you're saying oh but israel
it's millions of dollars from qatar in
there it true there is no blockade these
people are not game everybody has an
interest of you know they're prompting
their own political stands by by waving
the other side as making it the enemy
but then nothing changes everybody wins
everybody stays in power just people
suffer okay let's take one step back for
a moment
Alan mentioned Gaza smaller than the
Norwegian capital Oslo its population is
three times as high that is some two
million people and there's no doubt
about it the territory is a tough place
to live survival is a challenge in the
stony wastes of the Gaza Strip the
economy is in ruins
unemployment is stuck around 40 percent
people do everything they can just to
scrape by
economic activity is non-existent in
Gaza we're exhausted the situation was
made even worse when the u.s. froze aid
funding for the UN relief and Works
Agency the health system in Gaza is also
on the verge of collapse while the
population is soaring
the ongoing power struggle between rival
factions Hamas and Fatah have made the
situation even more precarious
for a year now Palestinian anger has
been unleashed in protests staged at the
border fence with Israel an estimated
200 Palestinians have died so far
thousands more have been injured is the
dream of a lasting ceasefire impossible
in the midst of hopelessness a place of
no hope a place that is as people
sometimes say unlivable is it yeah it is
it is true because there is a water
problem there is no water almost no
water and it's surrounded I mean the sea
and Egyptian border is really a border
it's cut and it is not one it is the
most densely populated place on earth
and if I want to quote an old Chomsky he
said it's the biggest open-air prison in
the world so this is Gaza
this is Chomsky yeah oh why not power is
that people in Gaza need on daily
consumption of visit yeah it's quite
spec is more densely populated than Gaza
this is I mean you know these are all
the things that they get water from
Israel they get electricity from Israel
if people are having a hard time in in
Gaza it's because they get money from
Unruh bar from the United Nations if
people are having a hard time in Gaza
it's because the elite of Hamas as
corrupt as the elite in Venezuela in
Tehran Saudi Arabia name it because they
are siphoning off the money from
themselves you know not because of any
Israeli blockade well I I think that
what I would like to suggest and and
this is exactly what I'm trying to talk
about the whole time how we break this
cycle I think Israel has been fall in
love with with using only sticks in the
last 10-15 years and forgot about the
idea of carrots as well as incentives
and maybe a tool of influence and policy
I think if there if when I'm talking
about bold moves there's no doubt there
needs to be change and some bold moves
within the Palestinian leadership both
in Hamas and PLO in the West Bank
their-their queen on for itself is it's
is also a big part needs to be put as
part big part of the blame of the misery
of the Palestinian people but again if
we're just so sick of this blame game
and we're trying to think okay how do we
try to make something better how do we
try to improve how do we try to make
ourselves you know to prevent ourselves
I'm sitting here in another year and
even a few months talking again about
the same problems and I'm thinking how
about trying to find different ways how
about trying to say okay we want to help
I mean there will be Qatar support there
will be also European support if you
want to break this cycle we want to
bring Gaza into a place where it can
sustain itself economically how do we do
that which carrots do we you like it
we're talking about the gas reservoirs
and you know on the Gaza shores we're
talking about in Airport all sorts of
infrastructure investments that Israel
so far is being very reluctant in
promoting or supporting for all sorts of
reasons some of them you know headed by
by military fears of what this would
mean but I find it to be that you know
Israel's superiority of military
superiority is such that what even when
things are wrong what then what I mean
it's gonna be so Israel is if Israel to
get the other hand to remain in the
upper home there's gonna be try some
carrots for a change well in
characteristic the carrots are coming
the Trump plant is coming we all know
what the Trump plan is gonna entail it's
gonna be who do state yeah give me give
me give me an insight okay so that's a
couple of weeks ago there's gonna be two
states but the Palestinian state
including Gaza with a land bridge
between Gaza and the West Bank and
they're not gonna have control over the
over the over the air space they're not
gonna have control over the Jordan
Valley to prevent terrorism and there's
gonna be massive investment in
desalination plants on the Gaza sure
they're going to get their own harbor
and their Airport but controlled by
Israel and we own and we
why the Palestinians are so they are
absolutely second-class citizens I am
not at all
talking about the palace I am talking
about legitimate needs of control when
Germany was considered was under before
German is reunited the Allies also had
control of our elements of our airspace
and so on and if you wanted to go to
Berlin you had to go through a certain
channel and so these are things air
corridor these are things that you need
to keep the peace I'm not talking
Palestine as a second-class citizens I'm
talking about giving them citizenship of
their own country I'll come back to you
immediately Assam I mean we're talking
now about Donald Trump he's had a huge
impact in the region that just have a
let's get a flavor of where he is coming
from in this debate because he's playing
an increasingly important role here
moving the American Embassy from Tel
Aviv to Jerusalem a year ago was a major
policy shake-up on the part of Donald
Trump among those attending the opening
ceremony was his son-in-law Jared
Kushner the presidential adviser plans
to present a peace plan for the region
this summer then last march the u.s.
officially recognized Israel's
sovereignty over the Golan Heights the
mountainous region in the country's
northeast was part of Syria until 1967
but Israel has occupied it ever since
the end of the six-day war the range has
important military significance for
Israel as a buffer zone and would give
it a strategic advantage in the event of
any military conflict with Syria
after making so many decisions so
heavily in Israel's favor can the US
under President Trump still be a
credible mediator in ongoing conflicts
in the Middle East is mr. Trump a
credible mediator would you buy the deal
off of him
oh not at all not at all and either I
don't understand what is the deal of the
century and what will come out of it but
I want to emphasize the fact that mr.
Trump is creating this or a planting the
seeds of destruction in different places
in the world including the United States
his voters some of them are anti-semites
mr. Netanyahu and the right-wing
government think that with Trump they
can bring the conflict with the
Palestinian into a happy end this is an
illusion the extremists who was shooting
the Jews in the synagogue in the United
States was a supporter of mr. Strom it's
not true say he in his manifest the
Pittsburgh shooter called Trump a tool
of the Jews now don't don't fake don't
fake news please and I never said that
he said that never it's in his manifest
everyone knows that this is no just like
the reads then shooter was an entity
we're running out of time I just like to
come back to a point one German magazine
this week said that the Palestinians
would likely be tempted to buy to buy
the deal that is going to be offered to
them because it will give them the
things that Alan is talking about houses
swimming pools schools for their kids
and all this okay when we have the deal
we can talk about it I'm not sure about
not confident I'm not sure about the
deal and I'm not sure that it will come
of any Emmy soon and I'm not sure that
thirty or forty years old we are it was
yeah yeah and a real estate lawyer green
blood are really able to solve or offer
because it is not a real state conflict
it is not okay what Jesus says it's not
my bread only that man can live the
israeli-palestinian conflict is not
about billions of dollar investment I
would like to hear what Shani has to say
about it because you were talking about
the carrots and the sticks are there
enough do you sense that there are going
to be enough carrots in this package to
somehow I'm not as confident as Alan I
have to say I I I do hope this this deal
of the century will be a comprehensive
package it will offer some some carrots
as well we have to keep in mind when you
bring it to the PAL you talk about
bringing it to the Palestinians and then
through issues here first of all the
complete break of confidence in in in
Trump and his government the lack of
willingness to talk negotiate have any
contact whatsoever there's this one
thing and then the second is who are the
Palestinians who is the leadership who
is the the official legitimate
representation presented of the of the
Palestinians if you look at Gaza if you
could say okay Hamas is leading Gaza
we're having people in come on from Gaza
themself telling us Hamas is not a true
authentic representer you know what we
believe in what we want you yeah I doubt
you would agree this is jihadi Islamic
Jihad that are representing then who is
definitely you don't see the PLO and
strong enough in Gaza to be the one
representing the Palestinians if you go
to the West Bank we're talking about a
president who is in his mid 80s with
with a very weak health condition hasn't
had elections in about I'd say 15 years
15 years in the Palestinian Authority so
the Palestinians themselves even giving
this opportunity I'm not sure they can
rise to the event and actually seize it
it's and that's even without discussing
problems on the Israeli side yeah it's
time you're naive enough to bake Middle
East problem is gonna be so easily
solved you too
no no I'm totally I totally expect that
the Palestinians will reject it they
will reject any deal they will reject
any deal because they don't really want
the two-state solution anymore and their
backers we have to respond a minute yeah
I mean it's not fair really easy said
you will see them on their fruits judge
them by their fruits and we've seen the
Palestinians reject everything come on
in just a moment you have no right to
talk on behalf of the Palestinian no
none of us do and also to come to
conclusion and to what how they will
deal with a situation so let us wait for
the deal of the century and we will talk
about it despite the fact that we never
got to talk about the Eurovision Song
Contest that have music in my ear
telling me that we have to wind down
we've been talking about conflicts and
peace in the Mideast I hope we've given
you plenty of food for thought and some
emotion on top thanks very much for
joining us bye-bye and truce
[Music]